president Trump highlights his plan to
rebuild the nation's crumbling
infrastructure in his State of the Union
address more than 54,000 of the 612
thousand bridges in the country are
structurally deficient according to a
report released this week Americans
cross these deficient bridges 170 more
million 74 million times a day Kris Van
Cleave is under one of them in Nashville
Tennessee Chris good morning good
morning we're under one of Tennessee's
busiest structurally deficient bridges
more than a hundred and ten thousand
people pass over it every day now a
structurally deficient bridge is safe
but it is showing its age and signs of
decay which means it has to be inspected
more frequently and bridges are really
just the beginning of the infrastructure
needs in the u.s. in Tennessee alone
there's about a 10 billion dollar
project backlog America's infrastructure
is in dire straits right now KC Dinges
is from the American Society of Civil
Engineers last year the group gave the
US infrastructure a d-plus they estimate
two trillion dollars over the next 10
years needs to be invested to keep
American infrastructure from falling
apart what are the most urgent
infrastructure needs in the u.s.
transportation is a huge need if you
look at the two trillion dollar gap over
10 years that we identified half of that
is in roads bridges and mass transit
systems so that's just three of the 16
categories that we've identified of
those 16 categories 12 received some
form of a D or poor rating including
roads schools and the public drinking
water system it is also time to rebuild
our crumbling infrastructure
last night President Trump unveiled his
intentions to push Congress to approve a
1.5 trillion dollar infrastructure plan
that plan would include Congress
redirecting 200 billion dollars of
federal funds from Amtrak and other
transit programs over 10 years while
calling for hundreds of millions of
dollars to come from cities states and
the private sector every federal dollar
should be leveraged by partnering with
state and local governments and where
appropriate tapping into private sector
investment to permanently fix the
infrastructure deficit those so-called
public-private partnerships
to work in urban areas but require
projects that generate revenue like toll
roads and airports just 35 states even
allow them Democrat Peter DeFazio is the
ranking member on the House
Transportation Committee
he believes Trump's infrastructure plan
could be dead on arrival if there's not
substantial federal funding cutting
other already underfunded transportation
programs to fund a new fanciful program
it's not going to happen it's it's a
non-starter with both sides of the aisle
in both houses the Trump plan isn't
expected to get to Capitol Hill for
another week or two and so details could
change in that plan but when it gets
there it's going to be competing for
attention with a host of other
priorities including daca funding the
government and the debt ceiling Norah
all right Chris makes me nervous seeing
you stand out of that bridge there it's
deficient but a really great report and
I keep thinking about how a good
infrastructure plan could not only sort
of reinvigorate this country it can
implore employ more people and just kind
of revitalize cities and communities and
in my you know you've got people on both
sides who could vote for it to which
what might be way too bipartisan
everybody wants to feel safe when you're
driving over a bridge I now think about
it you're driving say is this okay
it's very stuff